We're going to start today with two bloodbaths,
one that is taking place and one that could take
place a few months from now. The first one
is a bloodbath in the Fox News ratings. And
I know that this brings such great pleasure
to so many in my audience. Some feel bad,
but the most important thing is that this is
a bloodbath that is taking place without any
government overreach, without any suppression of
anybody's speech or anything of the sort. It is
a self-inflicted bloodbath for Fox News. Fox News
has lost half of its audience since firing Tucker
Carlson during that time slot. And there's a lot
of different interesting layers to this. And many,
many of you have been writing. Is this the end of
Fox News? Well, no, it's not the end of Fox News.
But is this the end of Fox News as we knew it?
Well, that's a different question. And we still
have to wait and see the outcomes of multiple
additional lawsuits that still remain in play,
even though the Dominion lawsuit has been settled
for 787 and a half million dollars. Salon article.
It's a bloodbath. Fox News loses more than
half of audience after axing Tucker Carlson.
It's not just Tucker Slot writes the article. Sean
HANNITY and Laura Ingraham's ratings are falling
to Hundreds of thousands of Fox News viewers
have switched off the channel after the network
fired top primetime host Tucker Carlson last
Monday. Substitute host Brian KILMEADE garnered
1.3 million audience members during that 8 p.m.
timeslot, down 56% from the 3.5 million viewers
who tuned in to watch Carlson last Wednesday,
according to Nielsen ratings. The dip allowed
MSNBC's Chris Hayes to overtake Fox in ratings, a
popularity contest that Carlson used to dominate.
The conservative host had an average audience
of 3.3 million people for all of 2022. It was
the second most popular program on cable
after Fox the five. It is stunning to me
that Fox's The Five is a popular show. It's
almost completely unintelligible, but I guess
it doesn't really matter when you're talking
about Fox News. Okay. We'll get back to that.
When approached for comment, Fox sent a statement
saying, For 21 years it's been the most watched
cable network and it has a team that's trusted
more by viewers than any other news source.
Media reporter Brian Stelter noted in a tweet that
Fox's audience ratings plummeted from 2.65 million
watching Carlson's final show to 2.59. Monday, 1.7
million. Tuesday, 1.3 million Wednesday. What's
fascinating about that is that the relatively high
ratings on Monday, which was Tucker's first show
gone, in other words, Brian KILMEADE First show
as the temporary host there. There was a lot of
curiosity, sort of like a rubber necking. How bad
is it going to be? It turns out it's really bad. I
mean, KILMEADE is not only meaningless to listen
to, but also extraordinarily un entertaining and
uncharismatic. And then a lot of people said,
well, if this is the replacement, then I'm out.
And it sort of has gotten worse from there.
So let's talk about this in a few different
context. First of all, this isn't one of those
oh, there's dirty tricks. There's free speech
suppression and people are being limited by
the woke mob or whatever else the case may be,
as we have now established ad nauseum. Tucker
Carlson had good ratings, but was a huge legal
risk for Fox. And remember, FOX is is unique as
a cable news network in that it garners the vast
majority of its revenues from fees that any of us
who have cable pay. Even though I don't watch Fox,
I have cable so I can watch the sports
and things like that. And a couple bucks,
I guess somewhere between two and $4 of my cable
subscription goes to Fox News. Even though I don't
watch Fox News. That makes Fox different than
many of these other channels in that the other
channels disproportionately rely on ad revenue.
So the issue with Tucker was not an issue of
audience. The issue was that he was a huge legal
risk. And so what Fox decided to do is to fire
Tucker Carlson. And I've already told you the
reasons why Tucker's program partially responsible
for disseminating the allegedly defamatory content
that led to the $787 million settlement with
Dominion responsible to some degree for the
content that led to the ongoing lawsuit from
Smartmatic. You have a former staffer of Tucker
Carlson's who has filed a lawsuit for alleged
discrimination and misogyny, sexism, all sorts of
that's a problem. And then you potentially have
another forthcoming lawsuit from Ray Epps, who
says that Tucker has made his life miserable by
playing up a conspiracy theory conspiracy theory
in which Ray Epps is some kind of FBI agent or
actor. Or instigating the January six riots. So
Fox that this is a huge legal headache. Maybe
one of the ways we can mitigate the damage
is we're going to end up having to pay is by
saying we've taken care of what was one of the
problems that caused these issues for us in the
first place. Fine that Fox News did that. No one
covers them into doing that. The viewers are mad
and they don't like Brian KILMEADE and
everybody is getting to make their own
decisions. Nobody's being coerced here. Now,
what's the counterpoint to all of this? While
it's nice to see Fox suffering, not because
we want to see people go hungry or whatever,
it's nice to see Fox suffering because they put
out such terrible propaganda that is actively
damaging and corrosive to American democracy and
thinking that it's good that bad content suffer.
It's alarming to see that a bunch of Fox's
audience is not going to say, Hey, you know
what? I'm going to get my news from the AP and
Reuters and for commentary. Listen to, you know,
I don't know, something much more moderate,
some editorial page or whatever the case may
be. A lot of the folks are furiously tuning out
of Fox News may well end up on even more extreme,
unhinged media outlets like Newsmax or Oann or who
the Hell knows what. And the United States has a
major problem with that. People have gotten hooked
on this sort of thing. As we've talked before,
Fox News in some senses over the last two years,
since the 2020 election, became a victim of the
monster it created, it knew. We now know from text
messages that they were perpetuating lies about
the 2020 election. They knew Trump didn't really
win. They knew that a van with sandwiches wasn't
really proof that Trump actually won Michigan or
they knew it, but they also knew their audience,
which they've created, expects them to tell those
lies. And so now we have a situation where people
are addicted to this stuff and they want their
manufactured outrage. They want their scapegoats.
They want their, you know, lines like they used
to get from Tucker about immigrants, make the
country dirtier and whatever else the case may
be. And this is everywhere. Just the other day, I
was at a Trader Joe's and there was a young couple
there, maybe mid to late twenties, and the guy was
a heterosexual couple, meaning there was a man and
a woman. And the man there, they were out. This
is so insane. It sounds made up, but it's all
too real. I was looking for a particular type
of popsicle that my girlfriend likes. It's. It's
tangerine, and apparently it's seasonal. So I was
looking and saying, Sir, ma'am, where is it? They
didn't have it, but in that same freezer area,
there's normally mochi. Mochi is delicious.
Absolutely delicious. Mochi. Ice cream. And
they were out of the green tea Mochi ice cream.
And a guy says to his girlfriend, Joe Biden
screwed up the dairy supply chain. And that's
why there's no effing mochi here. And I said,
this has to be a I'm sure this guy's kidding. I'm
sure this guy is kidding. And I kind of looked
over and he wasn't kidding. Okay. This is just
a little meaningless anecdote about the type of
completely unhinged scapegoating and outrage that
the Fox News audience wants. So a real problem for
Fox News. I'm sure they will figure it out unless
they end up with billions more in settlements.